Well, what exactly is
mandatory access control?
Why do we need it?
I think we already talked about that,
although the users,
it's people who actually
create information and
run applications that
manipulate such information.
But people work for a company or
a garment agency, we'll talk about that.
And it's really their employer and
somebody that's trusted by them
already acting on behalf of them,
should really be able to specify how
certain kind of data can be shared.
First of all, in taking the power of
deciding how the data should be shared
from the user, and, essentially,
you can think about the user being
told the right way to share this data
is based on this policy
that the company has.
And this policy could be, it may depend
on the kind of company that we have.
So, for example, hospitals with
electronic medical records and
stuff like that clearly
have patient records.
And we know that patient health
information, their health conditions,
information about them
is highly sensitive, and
who can see it has to be limited, and
how it can be shared has to be limited.
And it's not really up to just
the hospitals, they would want to do it.
But there are regulations
that force them to do this or
force them to control how
patient records can be accessed.
So in the context of so
are held information.
We have HIPAA, which is the regulation
the government imposes on anyone,
entities like hospitals,
that collect information that goes
into patient records, medical records.
And of course, there's a need
to share that information.
If you go see a different doctor,
they need to have access
your medical information.
But how access to it should be created?
It's not the particular person who does
data entry for a patient's record.
They don't get to decide
who else can see.
This has to be decided
by the hospital that's
informed by this regulatory
policy called HIPAA.
This is protecting people's
health information,
privacy, and things like that.
We said in mandatory access control,
it's not just the user owning a resource
and being able to control, but
it's really the user's
organizational company.
Hopefully, this example information,
being medical records,
convinces you that sharing
of information has to be
mandated by someone other than
the user who's creating it